عام
1999 من القرن الماضي ضرب زلزال مدمر
تركيا اثاره الكارثيه غيرت وجه الحكم
اطاحت بحزب الشعب الجمهوري لصالح حزب
العداله والتنميه اليوم وبعد ما يزيد عن
20 عاما تركيا في مواجهه اثار زلزال مدمرا
وانتخابات فهل سيقلب الزلزال الجديد الحكم
مره اخرى
[موسيقى]
باستمرار حزب العداله والتنميه في الفوز
انه قدم للناخبين مزايا ماديه معينه بصرف
النظر عن قاعده الناخبين القويه وهذه هي
المره الاولى التي يبدو ان هذا الامر لن
يعمل بسبب الاقتصاد بسبب التضخم الكبير
وارتفاع تكاليف المعيشه
الامر يضر بشده بجيوب الناس واعتقد ان هذا
هو السبب في ان هذه الانتخابات لا تبدو
مضمونه الفوز بالنسبه لاردوغان
في السوق فاكهه طازجه وخضار لكن شرائها
صعب الاحوال المعيشيه صعبه الليره التركيه
منهاره والتضخم كبير في الشوارع صور
لاردوغان واخرى لكمال كلتشار اوغلو كل
يحاول استثمار الكارثه بين وعود بالبناء
والانقاذ واتهامات بالمسؤوليه والتقصير
عوامل ترجح كفه كلتش دار اوغلو كالشيل
الفتي الذي يرغب بحكم مغاير لما عايشه منذ
20 عاما وعوامل ترشح كفه اردوغان استقطاب
اي جيولوجي محافظ يميل لكفه العداله
والتنميه لكن لا شيء يغير وجه الحكم في
بلد ما اكثر من زلزال
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات